Donc je vous ai rappelé que ces psaumes 2, c'est un psaume très messianique, très explicitement messianique, la plupart des psaumes les sont, mais il y a certains psaumes qui sont davantage.
C'est un psaume qui parle des nations qui sont révoltées, qui sont enfuries contre le lointre des dieux, les types du Christ.
À ces moments-là, c'était David notamment, qui était persécuté sans raison, un homme choisi par Dieu pour être les rois d'un peuple, un peuple qui était infidèle, et même les nations qui cherchaient à s'opposer à son royaume.
Comme il était les choisis des dieux, c'était les royaumes qui Dieu allait honorer, c'est le seul royaume qui peut prévaloir.
Et c'est intéressant de remarquer que, malgré l'opposition des nations, David était rassuré que plus tôt ou plus tard, Dieu lui-même allait réclamer l'autorité du vrai Messie.
Donc c'est un psaume qui parle avant tout du Christ, qu'au moment de sa crucifixion, même s'il a été confirmé par Dieu, révendiqué par l'Esprit dans son ministère, en opérant des miracles, en prêchant la parole comme jamais personne n'avait la capacité de prêcher,
Il a été quand même refusé, non seulement par son peuple, mais par les nations. Pilate représentant aussi les nations.
Jésus, je vous rappelle, a traversé plusieurs instances des jugements, le jugement de Sénédran, les jugements d'Hérode, les jugements de Pilate, et les peuples lui-même en faisant un choix.
C'est comme si tous ceux qui ont participé au jugement de Christ représentaient toutes les nations et les principales autorités des nations.
Et donc il a été refusé, ce qui révèle les niveaux de corruption de nos cœurs, de l'humanité.
Mais Dieu l'a révendiqué, d'abord par la résurrection, ensuite par les témoignages fidèles et les progrès de l'Église,
et bientôt il reviendra pour manifester explicitement et ouvertement sa royauté de manière irrésistible.
Nous sommes dans cette période de patience où nous pouvons profiter encore de cette grâce de Dieu qui nous invite, qui nous appelle, qui nous exhorte,
qui est en train de nous sommer à reconnaître la royauté du Christ, à nous soumettre à l'évangile de Jésus-Christ.
Et si nous ne le faisons pas, on sera du mauvais côté de l'histoire lorsqu'il crie, il reviendra.
Et la réalité, c'est que Dieu nous a appelés particulièrement, nous l'Église, de joindre cet appel aux nations.
Donc malgré les circonstances difficiles qu'on pourrait traverser dans nos vies, malgré les pressions culturelles,
nous devrions proclamer la royauté du Christ.
Donc ces assassinats qu'on a vus l'année dernière, les assassinats qui ont lieu encore aujourd'hui dans plusieurs pays contre les chrétiens,
n'ont jamais été efficaces contre les progrès de l'Église, au contraire.
C'était surtout par les 100 versets des martyrs que l'Érôme des dieux a avancé.
Et donc ici, quand on est devant les livres d'actes, on est notamment devant l'accomplissement suprême de cette commission, de ces mandats.
C'est-à-dire appeler les nations, et même les nations en furie, à embrasser les fils, à couronner les fils, à reconnaître sa royauté.
Nous voyons dans les contextes du livre d'actes que les seigneurs Jésus-Christ venaient d'être crucifiés.
Donc c'était un refus du roi des dieux qui était le plus explicitement manifesté.
Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est que les apôtres ici, ils sont devant une génération en furie contre Christ en tant que Messie.
Ils sont peu nombreux et ils reçoivent ces mandats d'aller servir en tant que témoins jusqu'aux extrémités de la terre.
Un commençant par Jérusalem.
C'est-à-dire, on va commencer par là où c'était le plus difficile.
Par là où le Christ lui-même a été crucifié.
Et donc, toutes les stratégies de nos jours qui semblent être trop sages pour être vraies,
des comment on peut naviguer avec beaucoup de ruses pour éviter les confrontations et les persécutions,
elles ne sont pas en harmonie avec les Écritures.
La croix porte sur les scandales.
Les problèmes pour les régés de l'Évangile n'ont jamais été un problème des manques de reconnaissance de la vérité à propos du Christ.
La lumière est venue au monde, mais les mondes ont préféré les ténèbres.
Ils ont voulu supprimer la réalité du Christ car ils aimaient plus leurs œuvres pécheresses que la lumière.
Donc, le problème des lettres, au moins, lorsqu'ils rejettent l'Évangile,
ce n'est pas qu'il manque de connaissances ou de reconnaissance qu'il Christ soit les rois,
qu'il soit la lumière du monde.
C'est un problème des corruptions du cœur.
Et donc, bien sûr qu'il y aura toujours de la limite pour notre apologétique,
notre manière de défendre la vérité.
Pensez que nous devons éviter certains sujets.
Vous pensez, par exemple, que dans notre partage de l'Évangile,
peut-être que si on montre qu'il y a beaucoup de réussites selon les mondes,
les personnes seront attirées pour la foi.
On est en train de chercher à attirer les perdus qui ont déjà l'idolâtrie pour l'argent, pour la réussite,
par des moyens idolâtres.
Bien sûr que les chrétiens s'y sont engagés dans leur appel de rendre gloire à Christ en tout.
C'est naturel qu'on cherche à faire tout avec excellence
et qu'on puisse être perçus dans la société comme des personnes qui ont une bonne performance.
Mais la réalité, c'est que la proclamation de l'Évangile, dans son essence,
est une proclamation qui va confronter directement les péchés humains.
Et ça va inévitablement produire une réaction,
soit la vraie répentance, la vraie conversion,
soit ça va devenir l'opposition.
Et donc, ces disciples ont reçu ces mandats dans un contexte extrême.
Ce qui fait que nous n'ayons aucun autre paradigme,
et ça c'est une autre chose à corriger dans l'Église aujourd'hui,
l'Église, elle ne peut pas se dire,
c'est comme ça que j'ai vu dans toutes les Églises,
donc peut-être que ça c'est en manière légitime de fonctionner.
Ce qui est là n'est pas toujours ce qui devrait être,
car nous n'avons qu'un paradigme, un paramètre,
pour apprendre ce qui est un chrétien, ce qui est une Église, ce qui est l'Évangile.
Et c'est la Bible, la parole des dieux.
Et donc, si l'Église, dans sa jeunesse, a commencé comme ça,
et si l'Église, dans le Nouveau Testament, a prospéré en restant comme ça,
pour toutes les générations, on doit revenir à ces paramètres pour vivre l'Église.
Paul écrit à Timothée en disant,
« J'ai écrit ces choses pour que dans mon absence,
tu saches comment procéder dans la maison des dieux. »
C'est-à-dire, ce n'est pas ouvert à nous ou à notre imagination
de chercher à être créatif dans notre manière de faire l'Église.
Et donc, si nous avons les paramètres primaires
de comment l'Église fait l'évangélisation,
ce qui est l'Église, ça doit rester pour toujours les paramètres
et les seuls paramètres pour nous.
Donc, nous sommes devant les circonstances les plus extrêmes
et nous sommes devant la réussite la plus puissante.
Ce qui reste pour nous, les paramètres pour qu'on n'ait jamais d'excuses.
C'est difficile, il y a beaucoup de pression,
peut-être qu'on va perdre l'emploi.
Oui, peut-être, mais eux, ils ont perdu leur vie.
Ils sont devenus des martyrs.
Et est-ce que ça a eu la capacité de freiner les problèmes de l'Église ?
Non, au contraire.
L'Église, elle a grandi, elle a prospéré,
elle s'épanouie comme ça.
Et donc, la question pour nous, c'est,
comment pouvons-nous avoir cette tardiesse dans la proclamation
et voir les résultats qu'ils ont vus ?
La réponse est la plus simple,
c'est en apprenant avec ces textes
les repères qui restent pour toujours
pour ce qui concerne ce qui est l'appel ou la mission d'un chrétien
et comment ils doivent l'exercer.
C'est simplement comment faire l'évangélisation
avec hardiesse et assurance.
Donc, acte 1, c'est l'accomplissement
dans la nouvelle alliance
qui sert des repères pour toutes les générations de l'Église
et cet appel qu'on doit apporter à toutes les nations
d'embrasser les fils, de reconnaître la royaire du Christ.
La vérité principale pour nous, c'est qu'à l'Église
a été confiés les privilèges et les devoirs
de s'associer à Dieu
dans cette œuvre certaine
d'appeler toutes les nations
et même les rebelles
à couronner les fils
comme rois et sauveurs.
C'est-à-dire,
Dieu est en train d'accomplir son descent
en appelant toutes les nations
à couronner les fils.
C'est cette mission des dieux dans l'histoire,
une mission des grâces.
Car, qu'on les veut ou pas,
à la fin des temps,
il sera les rois
et tous les rebelles seront lancés à l'enfer.
Et entretemps,
Dieu dans sa grâce
appelle aux personnes
de volontairement se soumettre à Christ comme roi,
l'honorer comme roi.
Et en les faisant,
Dieu a choisi nous, les chrétiens,
nous, l'Église,
pour être la bouche des dieux
aux nations,
pour être les héros des dieux aux nations,
pour être les ambassadeurs
du roi des dieux aux nations.
Des fois, nos enfants,
ils ont du trouble à l'école même,
ils se sentent sous pression
et ils peuvent se comporter
d'une manière qu'on n'approuve pas
car ils se sont sentis sous pression.
Ou parfois, ils souffrent beaucoup
avec certains copains
qui font des blagues
ou les méprisent.
Et quels sont les problèmes ?
J'utilise les enfants directement
car ça parle de nous aussi.
Pourquoi on ne se porte pas plus
comme des chrétiens ?
Pourquoi parfois,
on se sent trop blessé
par les mépris
qu'on nous porte
car on est chrétien ?
C'est un manque d'assurance
en termes d'identité.
Bien sûr qu'on n'est pas là
pour défendre, au contraire,
cet évangile de développement personnel
qui veut donner aux personnes,
même dans leurs conditions pécheresses,
une importance exagérée
qu'ils n'ont pas,
selon la Bible.
Nous sommes misérables,
pauvreté spirituelle.
Notre identité ne trouve
qu'est son importance,
sa richesse,
dans l'image des dieux
que Christ veut restaurer en nous
et car nous sommes
par la face aussi à Jésus
qui est le fils bien-aimé des dieux.
Donc avant de rélever
notre identité en Jésus-Christ,
notre identité,
elle est écrasée
en nous révélant
ce qui nous sommes
de nous-mêmes
dans notre rébellion.
Mais la réalité,
c'est que si nous avons compris
l'évangile,
l'identité
qui Dieu nous a donnée,
elle doit nous apporter
à la considération
du fait
que la vie
de la personne
qui emporte le plus
Dieu lui-même
envers moi
est inébranlable
et car je suis associé
à Christ,
je suis aimé
comme Dieu aime
Christ lui-même
et quelque part,
peu importe
la vie
que les autres personnes
ont par rapport à moi.
Donc la difficulté
pour nous
d'assumer notre identité
et d'être efficace
dans l'évaluation
est d'abord
une crise
d'identité chrétienne.
Comme les conseils
qu'on doit donner
à nos enfants.
Tu sais que chez nous,
tu as beaucoup de valeurs,
qu'on t'aime
de manière inconditionnelle
et donc
ne donne pas trop d'avis
ou d'importance
à la vie
qui t'écopant
manifeste envers toi.
Les personnes
qu'on apprécie le plus
sont celles
qui ont
la plus grande assurance
de soi
en termes de ses valeurs.
et il n'y a
aucune identité
qui puisse surmonter
l'identité
d'un chrétien
qui a tout perdu
lorsqu'il a compris
sa misère spirituelle.
Il n'a plus rien
à défendre.
Personne ne peut dire
des mauvaises choses
à propos de moi
qui puissent être pires
de la réalité
que j'ai la capacité
d'être.
Et en même temps,
la personne
la plus importante
de l'univers
me voit
comme elle voit
son propre fils
Jésus-Christ lui-même.
Donc cette personne
elle est inébranlable.
Elle peut avancer
sous les coups
et donner sa vie
au lieu de se ressentir
d'être hypersensible.
Elle est généreuse
dans ce qu'elle peut donner
et les coups
qu'elle peut recevoir
car son identité
est enracinée
dans des réalités
éternelles
dans un amour
infini.
Et quelle est l'identité
que ces textes
nous présentent ?
L'identité du chrétien
en plus d'être
ceux qui sont associés
à Christ
sont les représentants
du Christ sur terre.
Ils sont les ambassadeurs.
Lorsqu'il dit
« et vous serrez
mes témoins »
« vous serrez
ça veut dire
que nous
ne faisons pas
l'évangélisation.
L'évangélisation
est la manifestation
naturelle
de ceux qui nous sommes.
Et voilà pourquoi
quand on apprécie
des personnes
qui partagent
l'évangile
avec Ardiès
les martyrs
on ne peut pas
tout simplement
arriver aux personnes
et dire
« tu devrais partager
l'évangile
avec plus d'Ardiès »
car derrière
ces manques d'Ardiès
nous sommes devant
une crise d'identité
une mauvaise compréhension
de l'évangile.
L'évangélisation
est avant tout
une question d'être.
Si nous sommes
ou non témoins
de Jésus
car être témoin
c'est d'avoir vu
déprimièrement
les crises ressuscités.
C'est d'avoir connu
de manière expérimentale
les seigneurs
qui nous ont sauvés.
Ce n'est pas
une fois indirecte.
Personne ne peut être
un témoin
s'il n'a pas vu
contempler
l'événement
de manière directe
et personnelle.
et c'est ce qui est
présent dans ce texte
c'est que Dieu
nous a inclus
dans cet appel
c'est la raison d'être
car si Dieu
n'avait pas
un autre objectif
pour nous
après la conversion
il nous amènerait
au ciel.
La seule raison
pour laquelle
Dieu nous a préservés
là aujourd'hui
même dans l'emploi
où nous sommes
c'est pour
qu'il nous
pousse
accomplir
ce qui reste
de cette mission.
Et donc
Dieu accomplit
son descend
en appelant
toutes les nations
à couronner
les fils
et nous
chrétiens
nous servons
des bouches
de Dieu
pour appeler
les nations.
Et donc
comment l'Église
elle peut appeler
avec assurance
et efficacité
toutes les nations
et même les rebelles
à se soumettre
à son fils
sur quelle assurance
l'Église s'appuie
pour appeler
avec succès
les nations.
Quelles sont
les certitudes
qui rendent
cet appel
de l'Église
un appel
qui devient
irrésistible
et efficace
pour amener
les nations
à se mettre
à Christ.
Donc la question
centrale pour nous
c'est quelles sont
les bases
!
de l'assurance
de l'Église
dans les premiers siècles
qui ont permis
que cette Église
ait si tant
d'efficacité.
Et ma proposition
à nouveau
c'est que c'est
impossible
que l'Église
réussisse
si ce n'est pas
comme ça
et c'est impossible
que l'Église
ne réussisse pas
si c'est comme ça.
Donc la réalité
à nouveau
c'est l'Église
elle appelle
toutes les nations
et même les rebelles
avec efficacité
et assurance
à couronner
les fils
et je vous propose
quelques réponses
la première
lorsqu'il
l'Église
saisit
l'assurance
de la résurrection
du roi
qui nous mandate
c'est cette assurance
factuelle
de la résurrection
du Christ.
Donc
quand nous sommes
tièdes
dans l'évangélisation
cela veut dire
que nous sommes
en train de faire
l'évangélisation
comme si Christ
n'avait pas ressuscité
n'avait pas
vaincu la mort
comme si Christ
les ressuscités
avait vêtus
d'autorité
et nous avait pas
mandatés
car à partir
du moment
où nous craignons
plus les hommes
qui sont Dieu
qui ont crucifié Christ
qui sont les Christs
qui sont les hommes
qui ne peuvent pas
sortir de la tombe
et nous ne craignons pas
l'homme
qui a sorti
de la tombe
pour juger
tous les vivants
et tous les morts
et toujours.
Donc c'est une incohérente
qui devrait nous amener
même à mettre en question
la compréhension
du salut
l'authenticité
de la conversion.
Est-ce que votre salut
a été opéré
par les fils
des dieux
qui est mort
et ressuscité
et la conviction
du Christ
qui n'est plus
accroché à la croix
mais les Christs
qui est ressuscité
est-ce que c'est lui
qui vous a rencontré
est-ce que vous avez eu
les contacts
des premières
avec les seigneurs
Jésus ressuscité
d'entre les morts.
C'est lui
qui vous a sauvés
c'est lui
qui vous a commissionnés
qui vous a mandatés
à partager son évangile.
Voilà pourquoi
les premiers versets
que nous avons lus
nous parlent
de cette préoccupation
de Luc
l'auteur d'Actes
et de l'évangile de Luc
à cet homme
qui était en récent converti
Théophile
à qui il consacre
son premier livre
et son douzième
et en tant que médecin
comme était Luc
il a toute cette préoccupation
de faire une recherche
précise à curer
et qu'il écrit ces choses
et établit d'abord
cette fondation
dans l'évangile
pour prouver
que Christ était vraiment
le Messie
envers les dieux
et enacte
l'œuvre
du progrès
de l'Église
qui a été promise
qui est fondée
surtout
sur la résurrection
de celui
qui avait été crucifié
et donc il l'écrit
Théophile en disant
j'ai parlé dans mon premier livre
de tout ce que Jésus
a commencé à faire
et d'enseigner
dès le commencement
jusqu'au jour
où il fut enlevé au ciel
après avoir donné des ordres
par les Saint-Esprits
aux apôtres
qu'il avait choisis
après qu'il eut souffert
il leur apparu vivant
et leur donna
plusieurs preuves
se montrant à eux
pendant 40 jours
et parlant des choses
qui concernent
les royaumes des dieux
comme il s'est trouvé
avec eux
il leur recommanda
de ne pas s'éloigner
de Jérusalem
mais d'attendre
ce que les pères
avaient promis
ce que je vous ai annoncé
leur dit-il
car Jean a baptisé
d'eau
mais vous
dans peu de jours
vous serez baptisé
du Saint-Esprit
donc qu'est-ce que Luc
est en train de faire ici
il est en train
d'affermir
de communiquer
en niveau d'assurance
dans le cœur
des théophiles
qui les plus probablement
selon nos commentaristes
a commencé à avoir
cette influence
envers les romans
dont il faisait partie
donc c'était pour
affirmer cet homme
dans sa foi
afin qu'il puisse
témoigner
et pour les faire
il commence
en rappelant
l'importance
de la résurrection
du Christ
qui a apparu
à plusieurs personnes
qui pourraient
être appelées
pour qu'ils puissent
donner leur témoignage
oculaire
à propos de la résurrection
du Christ
et donc
la résurrection
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
avait besoin
d'être un fait
vérifiable
et voilà pourquoi
Christ
il va passer
40 jours
pourquoi ces dates
sont très importantes
donc on sait
qu'il a été crucifié
dans quelle date
les Pâques
il est ressuscité
dans quelle date
la fête
des premiers fruits
et dimanche
les premiers fruits
de toute la création
la résurrection
les premiers fruits
de la nouvelle création
les Seigneur Jésus
ok
et maintenant
il va passer
40 jours
on sait
que la Pentecôte
viendra
et que le Saint-Esprit
sera envoyé
au 50ème jour
c'est-à-dire
7 fois 7
perfection
pleine
ancienne création
accomplie
nouvelle création
inaugurée
49 jours
plus 1
Pentecôte
ok
et donc là
on a
l'inauguration
de cette nouvelle
alliance
mais
après son ascension
il passe
10 jours
jusqu'à ce qu'il envoie
le Saint-Esprit
donc pourquoi
il est resté
40 jours
donc il y a
une raison
notamment
factuelle
historique
notre foi
elle est fondée
et basée
sur des faits
historiques
sur cette
intervention
divine
dans l'histoire
pour accomplir
une œuvre complète
donc
incarnation
vie parfaite
pour substituer
notre manque
d'obéissance
punition
la croix
pour substituer
notre mérite
des punitions
et ensuite
il va ressusciter
pour prouver
par la résurrection
que Dieu
qui était satisfait
de l'œuvre
parfaite
qu'il a fait
à notre place
et son ascension
va couronner
la complétude
de cette œuvre
historique
dans les temps
la base
et la fondation
de notre rédemption
et la résurrection
il passe
40 jours
donc il y avait
une importance
en termes
des témoignages
c'est-à-dire
les apôtres
et les disciples
qui étaient avec Jésus
devraient être
des témoins
des témoins oculaires
fiables
à propos de la résurrection
de Christ
mais il y a aussi
une portion théologique
très importante
il fallait que Christ
les instruise
pour comprendre
l'importance
de la résurrection
pour la rédemption
pour qu'il soit capable
de continuer
de laisser pour nous
la fondation
du Nouveau Testament
donc une compréhension
théologique importante
instruction
mais c'est clair
que ces mandats
à évangéliser
étaient surtout
rassurants
car ils étaient
devant un roi
qui les envoyait
même à perdre
leur vie
tous les disciples
sauf Jean
tous les apôtres
vont mourir
par martyr
et Jean
va survivre
de manière surprenante
après avoir été
plongé
dans l'huile ardente
et la réalité
c'est que
quelle autre
réalité
plus rassurante
pour faire face
à la persécution
qu'est d'être
devant
les crucifiés
ressuscités
vous comprenez
l'importance
l'apôtre Paul
qu'est-ce qui va
changer complètement
sa vie
c'est lorsqu'il a
la rencontre
avec les Christ
ressuscités
et c'est la même
réalité pour nous
car même si Paul
était en train
de voir quelque part
des manifestations
visibles du Christ
ressuscité
il va attribuer
surtout à l'oeuvre
du Saint-Esprit
en disant
Dieu a révélé
son fils
au-dedans
de moi
et cette expérience
est l'expérience
de tous les croyants
tous les vrais chrétiens
s'ils sont vraiment
convertis
ils ont eu
à un moment donné
une expérience
des rencontres
avec les Jésus-Christ
ressuscités
même si
de manière
spirituelle
donc nous devons
proclamer
l'évangile
aux nations
même aux nations
en opposition
avec assurance
et hardies
car nous savons
que celui
qui nous a mandatés
c'est
un Seigneur
ressuscité
ou est morte
à victoire
en aiguillon
donc c'est très important
que d'entre
toutes les doctrines
qu'on cherche
à défendre
ou à prouver
même par les faits
historiques
on voit dans
le Nouveau Testament
que la doctrine
capitale
était la doctrine
de la Résurrection
car elle pointait
envers la complétude
de son œuvre terrestre
du Christ
la deuxième assurance
que nous devons
saisir
dans ces passages
c'est l'assurance
de la puissance
de Saint-Esprit
donc l'Église
elle va appeler
avec hardiesse
et efficacité
les nations
lorsqu'elle saisit
l'assurance
de la puissance
de Saint-Esprit
pour rendre
ces témoignages
efficaces
donc nous voyons
l'insistance
du Seigneur Jésus
comme s'il était
en train de dire
presque
n'osez même pas
à chercher
à faire
l'évangélisation
à témoigner
si vous n'êtes pas
remplis
de Saint-Esprit
restez
en Jérusalem
jusqu'à ce que
d'en haut
vous soyez
revêtus
par les
Saint-Esprits
donc il dit
au verset 4
comme il s'est
trouvé avec eux
il recommanda
de ne pas
s'éloigner
de Jérusalem
mais d'attendre
ce que les pères
avaient promis
ce que je vous ai
annoncé
leur dit-il
car Jean
baptisé
d'eau
mais vous
dans peu de jours
vous serez baptisé
du Saint-Esprit
pourquoi
l'Église
n'est pas
si efficace
dans nos jours
dans l'évangélisation
l'une des plus
grandes probabilités
c'est car
cette Église
n'est pas
remplie
de Saint-Esprit
n'est pas
sous l'onction
de Saint-Esprit
et particulièrement
par ses ministères
qui est l'un des ministères
primaires de Saint-Esprit
rendre l'Église
courageuse
et radique
puissante
pour proclamer
c'est clair
que les Saint-Esprits
représentent
l'inauguration
de la Nouvelle Alliance
dans le sens
où il habite
dans toutes les chaires
tous ceux
qui sont vraiment convertis
deviennent
habitation du Saint-Esprit
mais nous ne pouvons pas
négliger
que l'une des raisons
principales
pour lesquelles
le Saint-Esprit
vient habiter en nous
c'est pour nous donner
la puissance
pour témoigner
vous serez
mes témoins
lorsque le Saint-Esprit
descendra
sur vous
et c'est clair aussi
quand on lit
Actes des Apôtres
même si le Saint-Esprit
habite chez tous
les chrétiens
nous voyons à plusieurs
reprises des expressions
comme un étant
rempli du Saint-Esprit
ou par exemple
lorsqu'il prie
après que les apôtres
ont été emprisonnés
et le Saint-Esprit
vient
et branle l'espace
et les personnes
sont
renouvelées
dans leur ardias
pour proclamer
courageux
donc c'est évident
dans le Nouveau Testament
que nous avons
bien sûr
cette réalité
où le Saint-Esprit
habite
dans tous les vrais
chrétiens
mais aussi
l'enseignement
que les plus
on est remplis
de Saint-Esprit
les plus
courageux
hardis
les plus
héraldiques
nous sommes
dans les partages
de l'Évangile
les mieux
en fonction
en tant qu'ambassadeur
les plus
ces expériences
des renouvellements
spirituels
et des réveils
donnent à chaque fois
à l'Église
des périodes
de beaucoup plus
d'efficacité
dans la proclamation
donc c'est l'un des ministères
principaux
du Saint-Esprit
c'est de rendre
l'Église
consciente
de son autorisation
pour proclamer
car dans les termes
original
à chaque fois
que vous voyez
puissance
c'est lié
à la notion
d'autorité
lorsqu'il Christ
dit aux apôtres
toute autorité
m'a été donnée
dans les ciels
et sur la terre
elle est donc
et fête
des disciples
c'est une notion
des consciences
de tous les chrétiens
que nous avons été
revêtus
du Saint-Esprit
d'une autorité
d'une onction
si vous voulez
pour que nous puissions
partager l'évangile
de manière
héraldique
comme des ambassadeurs
et si nous n'avons pas
cette conscience
nous allons rater
l'attitude
avec laquelle
on devrait partager
l'évangile
car nous ne sommes pas
en train de conseiller
les personnes
dans une direction
de choisir
pour une religion
nous ne sommes pas
en position
de travailler
sur la base
des échanges
apologétiques
car pour plus
qu'on arrive
à défendre
avec toutes les raisons
bibliques
historiques
qui sont fiables
à propos de la résurrection
de la résurrection
nous savons très bien
qui est même
les seigneurs
de la résurrection
n'a pas converti
tous les cœurs
et donc
quel est l'enseignement ici
que nous soyons
fermes
dans nos convictions
à propos de la résurrection
du Christ
et que nous sachions
défendre
cette doctrine
plus qu'il n'importe
quelle autre
mais en même temps
que nous soyons
toujours dans la dépendance
de celui
qui peut rendre
cet appel externe
pour plus convaincant
qu'il soit
efficace
à l'intérieur
et c'est notamment
le Saint-Esprit
le seul capable
de travailler
chez celui
qui partage l'évangile
pour que nous partageons
l'évangile
avec cardiaque
pour que comme Paul
dit aux Galates
Christ soit placardé
devant vous
comme crucifié
c'est comme si
pendant Paul
qui prêche
le Saint-Esprit
travaille d'une telle manière
que l'évangile
devient visible
spirituellement
pour les personnes
c'est comme si
Christ était en train
d'être crucifié
à nouveau
visuellement
devant les Galates
par quel moyen
les Saint-Esprits
en faisant usage
de cette proclamation
de cette évangélisation
mais la réalité
c'est qu'à l'intérieur
la seule chose
qui peut rendre efficace
que les morts
reviennent à la vie
c'est l'intervention
du Saint-Esprit
donc sans le Saint-Esprit
vous n'allez pas avoir
les courage nécessaires
pour faire face
aux nations
sans le Saint-Esprit
vous n'allez avoir
aucune efficacité
pour faire l'évangélisation
mais oser faire
l'évangélisation
dans la dépendance
du Saint-Esprit
et vous allez constater
qu'il est fidèle
à remplir la promesse
du Christ
car des fois
on ouvre la bouche
même sans savoir
comment on va dire
les choses
mais rien qui est par
l'effet d'oser
ouvrir la bouche
oser partager l'évangile
nous percevons
la présence
du Saint-Esprit
qui est là
pour nous aider
pour nous conduire
et donc
nous avons
cette promesse
comme une nécessité
pour l'Église
et qu'on sache
reconnaître
que pour plus
que les Saint-Esprits
soient décrits ici
par la puissance
qui la porte
nous ne pouvons pas
confondre les Saint-Esprits
avec une puissance
domesticable
ce qui semble être
le cas
dans notre génération
de la part
de plusieurs Églises
comme si on pouvait
domestiquer
les moments du culte
où il va venir
et produire
son spectacle
comme s'il était
soumis
ou susceptible
à une danse
de la pluie
qu'on fait
à chaque lutte
pour voir
comment ici
il va descendre
c'est une personne
c'est la troisième
personne
de la Sainte Trinité
et si sa présence
n'est pas liée
à son ministère
principal
nous rendre capables
pour pouvoir
parler de l'Évangile
avec précision
et hardies
et transformer
les cœurs
des personnes
pour produire
les fruits
du Saint-Esprit
nos Églises
devraient être
exhortées
et se laisser
corriger
comme Paul a dû faire
avec les Corinthiens
qui ont dissocié
les dons du Saint-Esprit
par exemple
du fruit
du Saint-Esprit
la sanctification
et une proclamation
efficace
de l'Évangile
et donc
le Saint-Esprit
il va descendre
sur cette Église
et le Saint-Esprit
est donc
l'assurance
que nous devons saisir
les gages
de notre héritage
les prémices
de cette nouvelle création
de laquelle
nous faisons partie
c'est l'Esprit
du Christ
c'est cet esprit
d'onction
si vous vous rappelez bien
dans l'Ancien Testament
cet esprit d'onction
il communiquait
l'essence
des mandats
d'avoir été
commissionné
revêtu d'autorité
pour représenter
les Christ
donc c'est-à-dire
nous sommes
rédévables devant Dieu
car Dieu a choisi
tous les chrétiens
pour accomplir
cette mission
les apôtres
n'ont pas eu
la capacité
de finir cette œuvre
voilà pourquoi
nous sommes là encore
donc chaque chrétien
sera rédévable
devant Dieu
du privilège
qu'on a eu
d'avoir été
revêtu
de Saint-Esprit
pour proclamer
la vérité
pour faire
l'évangélisation
la troisième assurance
que nous voyons
dans ce texte
c'est la réussite
certaine
assurée
par les Christ victorieux
par les rois victorieux
donc c'est cette assurance
de cette réussite
qui est redoublée
par la déclaration
des anges
dans ces passages
donc là
au verset 8
il parle
de l'envoi
de Saint-Esprit
et au verset 9
le passage nous dit
après avoir dit cela
il fut enlevé
pendant qu'il regardait
qu'il les regardait
et une nouée
les déroba
de leurs yeux
et comme ils avaient
les regards fixés
vers les ciels
pendant qu'ils s'en allaient
voici deux hommes
vêtus des blancs
leur apparure
et ils dirent
homme galiléan
pourquoi vous vous arrêtez
vous
à regarder
les ciels
c'est Jésus
qui a été enlevé
au ciel
du milieu de vous
viendra
de la même manière
que vous avez vu
que vous l'avez vu
en allant
au ciel
ça c'est très important
il y a eu cette question
quand Jésus a parlé
de l'envoi
de Saint-Esprit
et il pose la question
est-ce que c'est
dans ces temps-là
que tu restaureras
les royaumes
des dieux
quelle était
la mauvaise compréhension
des disciples
à ce moment-là
c'est que
possiblement
l'envoi de Saint-Esprit
va représenter
un royaume
terrestre
du Christ
Israël
restauré
à une position
de prééminence
entre les nations
et Christ
va rediriger
la compréhension
car
pour plus
que des manières
terrestres
la prospérité
ou
les défaites
qu'Israël a vécues
dans l'histoire
représentaient
plus ou moins
les leçons spirituelles
c'est clair
qui est la libération
la rédemption
la délivrance
de l'Egypte
ou arriver
à la terre promise
représentait
comme le Nouveau Testament
nous laisse très clair
les réalités spirituelles
ce n'était pas
l'esclavage de l'Egypte
c'était l'esclavage
de péché
la question
a été toujours
la réconciliation
avec Dieu
et les royaumes
a été toujours
la terre promise
et le paradis céleste
Hebreu nous le dit
clairement
il envisageait
une ville
qui n'a pas été fondée
par les mains humaines
donc ils n'ont pas
la majorité d'entre eux
n'ont pas
réjoui des promesses
qu'ils ont reçues
car ils savaient
que la promesse
était d'une autre nature
et voilà pourquoi
Christ répond
aux disciples
en disant
c'est pas
à vous
de comprendre
les temps
ou les époques
que Dieu a réservées
pour son exclusive
connaissance
mais vous
vous allez recevoir
le Saint-Esprit
et vous allez
être mes témoins
quand Jésus dit ça
il parle
de
chronos
et kairos
c'est cette dynamique
un peu triste
de l'église aujourd'hui
qui n'ont pas compris
les avertissements
du Christ
par rapport
à la fin des temps
et on essaye
de prendre
un horloge
et de dire
c'est maintenant
ou c'est dans un mois
c'est lié
à cet événement
ou l'autre là
et là
on essaye
de pénétrer
dans des mystères
que Dieu
n'a jamais permis
mais il parle
plutôt du chronos
du kairos
pardon
qui veut dire
sur la perspective
des dieux
souverrants
supratemporels
quelles sont
les grandes phases
qui composent
son grand plan
de rédemption
il y a eu
un kairos
qui s'accomplissait
ici
les temps
de l'opportunité
de l'incarnation
du fils
et son oeuvre terrestre
cette intervention
divine
dans l'espace
et les temps
humains
afin d'établir
les bases parfaites
de notre rédemption
à partir de maintenant
les fils ressuscités
réviants au ciel
dans son ascension
et les kairos
pour vous
quel est
l'aspect
déterminant
de cette saison
qui reste
à s'accomplir
c'est un Christ
qui règne
depuis le paradis
à travers
son église
qui a
comme kairos
comme objectif
principal
dans ces temps
être témoin
à toutes les nations
ne soyez pas
si focalisés
dans les chronos
soyez
focalisés
dans les mandats
qui vous est
réservés
pour accomplir
cette étape
et c'est Christ
qui vous avait vu
allant au ciel
va revenir
tant
que vous soyez
en train
d'accomplir
ce qu'il a
réservé
pour cette saison
eschatologique
pour l'église
donc l'église
n'est pas appelée
à chercher
comme Pierre
a été réproché
quelque part
après avoir
dans la montagne
de la transfiguration
l'anticipation
du Christ
et la société glorifiée
qu'est-ce qu'il a dit
à Christ
faisons trois tentes
faisons
les
conférences
d'adoration
extravagante
on va être
toujours à la recherche
de contempler
les anges
peut-être
qu'il va venir
avec un plateau
d'or
et la clé
d'une nouvelle voiture
pour moi
qu'est-ce que
les anges
diraient
à ce type
d'église
allez
allez faire
l'évangélisation
allez témoigner
si vous voulez
vraiment
voir
la vision
béatifique
du Christ
si vous voulez
contempler
la seule chose
qui peut remplir
vos cœurs
des joies
les retours
glorieux
de votre
sauveur
si c'est Christ
qui vous manque
dans tout ça
si c'est à lui
qui vous cherchez
dans tout ça
la manière
la plus rapide
de les retrouver
de les revoir
de marcher
en profonde
intimité
spirituelle
avec lui
et de contempler
son retour
c'est en vous engageant
à ce qu'il a prescrit
il va revenir
de la même manière
que vous l'avez vu
monter au ciel
il reviendra
du ciel
et tous les peuples
verront
mais pour qu'il revienne
c'est votre
kairos
de témoigner
de faire
l'évangélisation
comment ne pas
avoir cette assurance
celui qui est
ressuscité
d'entre les morts
il n'a pas fait
une suggestion
à l'église
il n'a pas dit
essayez d'être
mes témoins
en Jérusalem
en Judée
et en Samarie
et en Exéminité
de la terre
dans aucun moment
la mission
que Christ nous a donnée
elle est susceptible
des doutes
il dit
moi
je bâtirai
mon église
vous comprenez
pourquoi
dans la plupart
des cas
les manques
des réussites
de l'église
n'est pas
les manques
des capacités
du Christ
c'est les manques
d'assurance
de l'église
c'est son incapacité
de saisir
la promesse
son incapacité
de saisir
son identité
si nous contemplons
parfois
certains politiciens
ministres
et on apprécie
sa réputation
la manière
dont ils peuvent
être traités
etc
on nourrit
un certain type
de respect
envers eux
on devrait être
en sens
des respects
infiniment
supérieurs
envers nous
même
pas pour réclamer
les respects
des personnes
mais pour être
assurés
dans notre identité
nous sommes
ses ambassadeurs
les rois
il a été élevé
devant nos yeux
les faits
qu'il a été élevé
au ciel
communique
les choses
les plus importantes
de la partie
de l'évangile
ça veut dire
qu'il va
pénétrer
les ciels
pour accomplir
la fondation
de salut
donc tout
est accompli
qu'il sera
assis
à la droite
du père
pour occuper
les trônes
de l'univers
pour gouverner
chaque second
chaque millimèze
de second
de l'univers
selon
son bon plaisir
il est là
un temps
qu'homme
et Dieu
en même temps
pour intercéder
comme suprême
sacrificateur
pour les biens
et l'efficacité
de son église
et voilà pourquoi
il dit
toute autorité
m'a été donnée
dans les ciels
et sur la terre
les rois
ne peuvent rien faire
les autorités
donc
recevez
ces privilèges
de faire
ces royaumes
prospérer
réussir
assumer
votre identité
les Christ victorieux
il est en train
de monter au ciel
triomphant
pour prouver
que son retour
est certain
et que c'est à nous
de faire avancer
son royaume
par l'évangélisation
la quatrième
source d'assurance
dans ces passages
c'est de participer
à la promotion
du règne du Christ
en communion
constante
avec sa présence
spirituelle
par la prière
et par la prière
communautaire
car c'est très important
comme disait Calvin
qu'on comprenne
que toutes les bénédictions
que Dieu a mis
à disposition
à nous
à travers Christ
Christ a tout conquis
avant
Dieu devrait traiter
l'humanité
par sa justice
et par une espèce
de grâce
qui avait été
anticipée
envers nous
dont on ne méritait pas
pour nous donner
l'occasion
de la répentance
et de la réconciliation
mais l'exigence
sur la nature
sainte et Dieu
envers une humanité
en juste
c'était de nous punir
et pas de nous bénir
par contre
une fois
que Christ a
accompli
effectivement
cette justification
donc il a souffert
ce qu'on devrait
souffrir
afin de nous donner
son crédit
pour qu'on puisse
être bénis
c'est à dire
il n'y a plus
aucun empêchement
en Dieu
pour nous donner
libéralement
toutes les bénédictions
qu'il aimerait
nous donner
et Calvin
il avait l'habitude
de dire
que la prière
n'est rien que
la manière
dont Dieu
a déterminé
pour que nous
puissions
éteindre nos mains
afin de recevoir
les bénédictions
qu'il a déjà
voulu nous offrir
il a déjà
réservé pour nous
et notamment
ces prières
seront accordées
selon la conformité
de nos prières
à ce qu'il y a
de mieux pour nous
par la perspective
de Dieu
Dieu n'est pas là
pour sponsoriser
notre idolâtrie
il est là
pour extraire
et produire
le mieux en nous
et les types
de prières
que Dieu répond
sûrement
sont les prières
qui sont liées
surtout
à la mission
la plus élevée
qu'il nous a donnée
être ses témoins
osez prier
pour que Dieu
vous donne
de l'opportunité
à partager l'évangile
et de les faire
avec ardias
tester Dieu
à cet égard
et pourquoi
car si Christ
attention
il est pénétré
au ciel
en tant que roi
bien sûr
mais il est pénétré
au ciel
pour continuer
son ministère
en tant que
suprême sacrificateur
qu'il a commencé
sur terre
il a été des sacrifices
parfaits
mais il fallait
prendre ces sacrifices
s'approcher
du trône
des grâces
au temple
et maintenant
il est au paradis
en s'approchant
du vrai trône
spirituel
et il est en train
d'intercéder
en faveur
de son peuple
du progrès
de l'église
c'est à dire
qu'à chaque fois
que l'église
s'approche
d'un élu
pour partager
l'évangile
quelqu'un
qui va être sauvé
les seuls
jésus
est déjà là
en train
d'intercéder
pour eux
et nous sommes
par la prière
en train
de nous joindre
à Christ
dans cette communion
des prières
entre trinitaires
afin d'accorder
nos prières
à ces prières
et par là
nous avons
ces contacts
directs
comme dit
John Piper
pour contempler
par une perspective
un peu militaire
c'est comme
les radieux
qu'on utilise
dans les guerres
on est
en pleine bataille
en faisant
le rhum des dieux
avancer
devant des nations
opposées
mais une fois
qu'on est
en pleine communication
et constante communication
avec les générales
nous sommes rassurés
qu'il enverra
les secours
et son secours
sera efficace
on n'a rien à craindre
cette assurance
du fait
que Christ
il est là
dans son ascension
dans les trônes
de l'univers
et qu'il nous a promis
qu'il ça va réussir
la cinquième assurance
dans les passages
c'est cette prédication
au chapitre 2
qui fait Pierre
et c'est très important
de remarquer là
les paradigmes
les plus importants
de comment
les disciples
en acte
ils sont en train
d'accomplir
la commission
ou la mission
de psaume 2
c'est là
on voit
de la manière
la plus explicite
quelle est
la caractéristique
principale
de cette nouvelle alliance
et quels sont
les rôles
prééminents
de Saint-Esprit
lorsqu'il descend
sur l'église
à quel moment
Christ décide
d'envoyer
les Saint-Esprit
c'est beau
les jours
de la Pentecôte
ils étaient
tous ensemble
dans les mêmes lieux
tout à coup
il vend
du ciel
en bruit
comme celui
d'un vent
empêtué
et ils remplissent
toute la maison
où ils étaient
assis
des langues
semblables
à des langues
de feu
leur apparurent
séparées
les uns des autres
et s'éposèrent
sur chacun d'eux
et ils furent
tous remplis
de Saint-Esprit
et s'émirent
à parler
d'autres langues
selon que l'Esprit
leur donnait
de s'exprimer
or il y avait
en ces jours
à Jérusalem
des Juifs
en pieux
et toutes les nations
qui sont
sous le ciel
au bruit
qui eut lieu
la multitude
d'Akourou
et elle fut
confondue
par que chacun
les entendait
parler
dans sa propre langue
ils étaient
tous dans l'étonnement
et la surprise
et ils se disaient
les uns aux autres
voici ces gens
qui parlent
ne sont pas
tous galiléens
et comment
l'entendons-nous
parler
dans notre propre langue
chacun
dans notre langue maternelle
donc ensuite
c'est cité là
toutes les
les langues
ou nations
représentées
moi je partage
la vision
du commentariste
F.F.
Bruce
qui dit
que c'est impossible
d'associer
cet épisode
à ce qui est discuté
en Corinthien
c'est clair ici
que les langues
qui ont été
communiquées
ont été
comprises
dans les langues
terrestres
et que ces langues
qui ont été
communiquées
ont été des langues
qui ont été
communiquées
comme des signes
pour communiquer
les merveilles
de Dieu
dans la Bible
sont les actes
rédempteurs
de Dieu
c'est de quelle manière
les plans
de la rédemption
se développent
donc on n'a pas
le temps ici
pour rentrer
dans tous les détails
mais la réalité
c'est que la distinction
doit être perçue
et claire
dans les lettres
au Corinthien
il y a cette possibilité
que les langues
ne soient pas
intelligibles
pas compréhensibles
et qu'on ait besoin
d'un interprète
qui aurait reçu
un don spirituel
pour interpréter
ce type de langage
cette possibilité
elle est là
c'est clair
que ce qui se passe
en Corinthien
n'est pas accompagné
de ces signes
c'est à dire
la descente des langues
c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup plus lié
à l'inauguration
de la nouvelle alliance
car c'est lié
à la question
de la tour des Babels
et maintenant
c'est Dieu
qui est en train
de réunir
toutes les nations
par la proclamation
du Fils
envoyé
pour les saluts
de toutes les nations
donc si on veut
réclamer
de la similarité
dans certains aspects
on devrait par cohérence
chercher la similarité
dans presque tous les aspects
mais la réalité
c'est que
ce qui est communiqué ici
l'objectif principal
de cette descente
du Saint-Esprit
dans la nouvelle alliance
c'est que
l'évangile
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ
la couronnation
du Christ
en tant que roi ressuscité
soit proclamé
ou soit témoigné
à toutes les nations
donc c'est
le Saint-Esprit
comme Christ lui-même
avait dit
qui descendra
sur vous
sur toute chair
afin que vous soyez
tous revêtus
des puissances
pour proclamer
la vérité
donc la quatrième
pardon
la cinquième
source d'assurance
c'est la proclamation
revêtue du Saint-Esprit
de l'évangile
de Jésus-Christ
c'est cette assurance
de cette conquête
donc on ne peut pas aller
partout dans les passages
mais nous voyons
que comme résultat
de cette proclamation
Pierre s'élève
au milieu d'eux
donc Pierre
qui est Pierre ici
pour nous
c'est celui
qui après la crucifixion
du Christ
qu'est-ce qui se passe
avec Pierre ?
il va rénoncer
les Christ
et même après
qu'il ait vu
Christ ressuscité
pour plusieurs jours
il a même réfléchi
peut-être
à revenir
à son ancienne carrière
au lieu de vivre
à tampon
pour les ministères
encore accroché
dans son ancienne carrière
et Christ doit aller
les voir
pour les redresser
mais c'est
qu'est-ce qui est
maintenant
que ces pierres
oscillant
déviant
ces géants
pour notre foi
lorsqu'il est
Saint-Esprit
sans part de lui
et qu'il élève
l'autre voix
et qu'il prêche
un serment
très confrontatif
envers ceux
qui ont crucifié
les Christ
un serment très polémique
bien sûr fondé
sur les Écritures
mais qui prouve
que les modèles
que nous voyons ici
c'est les modèles
pour toujours
pour l'Église
les moyens les plus efficaces
pour la conversion
des personnes
pour l'avancement
du règne de Dieu
ce sont les prédications
héraldiques
remplies du Saint-Esprit
et lorsque l'Église
ose
chérir
ces moyens de grâce
!
mettre en valeur
lorsque l'Église
ose
promouvoir
des hommes
des dieux
qui puissent
se consacrer
à la prière
aux études
qui puissent
ne pas partager
leur temps
avec d'autres choses
dans cette vie
pour être
arrégimenté
comme il faut
pour cette œuvre
je crois
j'ai la pleine conviction
que nous ne voyons
plus
ou pas plus
les progrès
de l'Église
car nous ne voyons pas
cette conviction
ces niveaux d'assurance
quand on voit
l'Église
qui va naître
en Antioche
plus tard
dans les livres d'actes
c'est une Église
qui naît
de manière spontanée
par des disciples
et lorsque Jérusalem
voit ça
elle en voit
les mieux qu'elles ont
Barnabas et Paul
pour être un plan
à cette Église
pour amener cette Église
à son plan potentiel
et quels sont les moyens
principaux
à travers lesquels
cette Église
va prospérer
l'enseignement
et la prédication
de l'Évangile
et quels sont les résultats
pour la première fois
les disciples
qui sont appelés
chrétiens
petits Christ
donc nous devrions
chérir
promouvoir
diffuser
l'Évangile
rempli
de son esprit
et proclamer
de manière
héraldique
assurée
de manière
confrontative
parfois
et surtout
de manière
biblique
car son serment
est bien structuré
sur la parole
des dieux
et pour conclure
les textes
vont finir
ces cycles
d'inauguration
de l'Église
avec la description
de cette efficacité
l'Église
elle grandit
des 120 personnes
on passe
à 3000 personnes
rien qui est par
une prédication
remplie
de son esprit
et les convertis
qui sont
de plusieurs nations
différentes
c'est-à-dire
l'Évangile
va progresser
de Jérusalem
et Samarie
pardon
Jérusalem
et Judée
et Samarie
jusqu'aux extrêmes
de la terre
c'est les déroulés
du livre d'actes
mais cet événement
inaugural
il est déjà
une avant-première
et une assurance
pleine
que nous avons
pour être sûr
que ça va toujours
se passer comme ça
si nous tenons ferme
à ces principes
à ces modèles
et voilà pourquoi
tant de personnes
et tant de nations
converties
et quels sont les résultats
la dernière source
d'assurance
dans ces passages
c'est la manifestation
visible
du règne céleste
ou de l'ambassade céleste
sur terre
l'Église
pourquoi l'Église
ne prospère plus
dans son témoignage
dans son évangélisation
pourquoi elle n'est pas
en train de grandir
comme il faut
car
Jésus lui-même
nous a dit
que si vous vous aimez
les uns les autres
ils vous reconnaîtront
comme des disciples
comme disait
Francis Schaeffer
la preuve apologétique
suprême
de la réalité
de l'Évangile
ou du Christ
entre nous
qui règne sur nous
c'est l'Église
c'est la preuve
sociologique
ultime
si une Église
ne sait pas chérir
la prédication
n'est pas là
assidue
pour prier
si l'Église
n'est pas en train
de préserver
toutes les identités
ou les moyens d'assurance
que nous avons
vu dans ces textes
difficilement
cette Église
doit prospérer
si les pasteurs
se sentent toujours
domestiqués
par les attentes
du public
la valeur
que nous donnons
à la vie d'Église
elle est
directement liée
à l'efficacité
pourquoi ?
car si Christ
est couronné roi
dans nos cœurs
il doit être
couronné roi
surtout là
où il a communiqué
une autorisation
formelle
et officielle
donc l'institution
pour plus qu'on soit déçu
avec les Églises
parfois
on ne peut jamais
marcher
vers l'autre extrême
on doit s'assurer
d'abord
que l'Église
est biblique
si elle fonctionne
selon les paramètres
qui sont ici
pour être sûr
qu'on a trouvé
une Église biblique
mais à partir du moment
qu'on a trouvé
une Église biblique
il faut nous rappeler
que Dieu
ne nous a jamais
sauvés dans un vide
Dieu a sauvé
ces personnes
dans l'Église
et pourquoi ?
car ces Christ
qui étaient
montés au ciel
il exerce
son autorité
et il fait avancer
son royaume
par une expression
visible sur terre
à travers des Églises
réelles
concrètes
palpables
et voilà pourquoi
il dit aux disciples
en Matthieu 28
toute autorité
m'a été donnée
!
il a été donnée
dans les ciels
et sur la terre
allait donc
fête des disciples
en les baptisant
c'est-à-dire
les baptêmes
il est un outil
d'institution
formelle
par lesquelles
une personne
qui professe
publiquement
la foi en Christ
est assimilée
à l'intérieur
d'une Église
cette autorité
reconnue
a son efficacité
et donc nous ne devrions
jamais nous éloigner
et le problème
c'est que
on utilise tellement
la créativité
pour essayer
de faire l'Église
grandir
à notre manière
qu'on oublie
que la manière
honorée par Dieu
de faire grandir
son Église
et la manière
biblique
donc regardons bien
de manière
très naturelle
les versets
41-47
ceux qui acceptèrent
la parole
furent baptisés
c'est-à-dire
ils ont eu
cette reconnaissance
publique et formelle
leurs noms
ont entré
dans une liste
des membres
car ils ont pu
compter
des 120
à 3000 personnes
et en ce jour-là
le nombre
des disciples
s'augmenta
d'environ 3000 âmes
ils persévéraient
donc quelle est
la vie de l'Église
qui Dieu honore
quelle est la vie
de l'Église
qui communique
Dieu et notre roi
ils persévéraient
dans l'enseignement
des apôtres
dans la période
des Calvin
un vrai réveil
cinq jours par semaine
l'Église s'est rassemblée
pour entendre la prédication
cinq jours par semaine
prédication
ce n'était pas un jour
pour les mercredis
du réveil
ou les mardis
du chassement
des démons
ou les jeudis
des communes
c'était pour faire
ceci
les nombres
des disciples
s'augmentaient
dans le ventre
et persévéraient
dans l'enseignement
des apôtres
les apôtres
bien sûr
ne sont pas
ces soi-disant
apôtres de nos jours
c'est les douze
un nombre fixé
car même dans la gloire future
on a ces nombres fixés
douze tribus
douze apôtres
c'est fini
dans la communion fraternelle
donc un vrai amour
à quel point
au point qu'ils partageaient
même leurs propres biens
pour s'écourir
ceux qui étaient dans les besoins
une église persécutée
dans la fraction du pont
ici c'est la sainte-saine
donc on voit
les deux éléments constants
!
de rendre visible
ce qui est la vraie église
participation à la sainte-saine
et participation au baptême
et dans les prières
moi je suis convaincu
qu'ici on est sûr
que nos églises
sont en train de faire
ces activités
dans la même fréquence
et selon la même hiérarchie
qui sont trouvées ici
d'abord on ne va pas
trouver du temps
pour faire d'autres choses
les ministères des danses
des théâtres
car si on veut donner
l'opportunité
pendant les cultes
à tous les dons
qui sont dans l'église
on devrait même appeler
les fermiers
à enlever les laits
la vache devant nous tous
pour la gloire de Dieu
car tout est fait
tout est fait
pour la gloire de Dieu
et quel était l'esprit?
c'était pas
une attitude mêleuse
envers Dieu
c'était pas cette intimité
mêleuse
ils avaient beaucoup de joie
mais
la crainte s'emparait
de chacun
et il s'effaissait
beaucoup des prodiges
et des miracles
par les apôtres
donc cette précision
elle est importante
c'est pas pour dire
que Dieu n'opère plus
des miracles
mais ces miracles
qui étaient
de manière beaucoup plus généreuse
opérés par les apôtres
servaient à confirmer
leur autorité apostolique
et le fait qu'ils allaient
nous laisser en fondement
sur lesquels
on devrait se baser pour toujours
l'ancien mâle des apôtres
donc j'ai dit
pour conclure
que d'abord
on n'aurait pas les temps
pour faire d'autres choses
mais après
la joie serait tellement grande
l'assurance
serait tellement grande
qu'on n'allait pas voir
aucun besoin
pour d'autres choses
il y a plein de choses
qui nous pouvons vivre
en dehors du cadre
de nos réunions publics
en tant qu'église
mais qu'est-ce qu'on doit vivre
quand on est rassemblé
en tant qu'église
qu'est-ce qui est biblique
donc
ils vendaient leurs propriétés
et leurs biens
ils ont partagé
les produits entre tous
selon les besoins de chacun
donc là
la contribution régulière
selon les besoins
ils étaient chaque jour
tous ensemble assidus
dans les temples
et ils rompaient
les pans dans les maisons
et prenaient leur nourriture
avec joie
et simplicité des cœurs
louant Dieu
et trouvant grâce
auprès de tous les peuples
vous voyez
quels sont les moyens
les plus efficaces
d'évangélisation
ce n'est pas forcément
les tracts
même si ça a son lieu
ce n'est pas
les sorties évangélistiques
même si ça a son lieu
mais ce sont les personnes
remplies du Saint-Esprit
ce sont des personnes
qui vivent la vie d'église
avec tellement
de responsabilités
qui réjouissent tellement
de cette intimité avec Dieu
de ses sens
des missions
des consciences d'identité
que c'est impossible
que lorsqu'on soit dehors
on ne soit pas
témoin du Christ
qu'on ne soit pas
reconnu comme petit Christ
Marc Dever
il partage
un témoignage de conversion
assez intéressant
dans son église
c'était un sociologue
qu'il venait à visiter
convaincu
que l'église
était un phénomène sociologique
mais comment
une église
aurait pu prospérer
comme leur église
était en train
de prospérer
en Washington
aux Etats-Unis
dans une génération
si sceptique
donc il vient visiter
à plusieurs reprises
et il ne trouve pas
des explications sociologiques
pour la réalité
et il est de plus en plus
convaincu
de la réalité
de l'évangile
et il s'est converti
là-là
il y a aussi
cet aspect spirituel
dont parlait Jones
une femme
qui était animiste
qui était habituée
à des religions
animistes
elle est venue
et par l'assemblée
rassemblée
en donnant
l'attention
et l'honneur
qu'il faut
à la présence
du Christ
entre nous
elle dit
j'ai ressenti
une présence spirituelle
si puissante
comme j'ai ressenti
les présences spirituelles
dans mes cercles religieux
la différence
c'est qu'ici
c'est un esprit pur
c'est un esprit bon
c'est comme ça
qu'on doit percevoir
la présence
du Saint-Esprit
entre nous
ressentir
qu'on n'est pas là
tout simplement
pour satisfaire
nos intérêts
intellectuels
par rapport à la foi
donc il y a
quelque chose
qui se passe
lorsqu'il y a
l'église
et l'assemblée
qu'on ne peut
trouver nulle part
et c'est cette notion
d'être
organiquement
les corps du Christ
manifestés
et d'être
institutionnellement
ou formellement
l'ambassade
du royaume
du Christ
sur terre
et si
on n'a pas plus
d'ardiesse
dans notre partage
de l'évangile
c'est car on n'est pas
en train de vivre
la vie d'église
comme il faut
car ça devrait
faire brûler
notre cœur
d'être assemblée
et renouvelée
dans notre appel
pour partager l'évangile
donc j'espère
pour la conférence
mais surtout
en commençant
pour nous ici
nous soyons
rénovelés
dans ces sources
d'assurance
que Dieu nous a donné
celui qui nous a
mandatés
est l'Écrit
ressuscité
il nous a envoyé
son esprit
pour nous rendre
capables
de proclamer
avec ardiesse
et courage
il nous a assuré
que ça va marcher
car il est déjà
sous son trône
il va revenir
et c'est le cas
heureux pour nous
de proclamer
l'évangile
il nous a donné
des évidences
de l'efficacité
de la prière
et de sa parole
il répond aux prières
il manifeste
sa puissance
pour sauver
et il nous a donné
l'Église
pour que par
l'intensité
de notre vie ensemble
sous l'enseignement
de la parole
et la vie
de tous ces éléments
ensemble
nous serons en train
de renouveler
notre ardiesse
notre courage
et inévitablement
si nous sommes résolus
à renouveler
cette assurance
et oser proclamer
avec assurance
nous allons voir
les résultats
Amen
et vont nous pour prier